our subject for today dressed for the
occasion what did i say dress for the occasion
and god spake all these words saying i am the
law thy god which have brought thee out of
the land of egypt out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me thou
shalt not make unto thee any grievan image or
any likeness of anything that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or that
is in the water under the earth thou
shalt not bow down thyself to them nor serve them
for i the law thy god am a jealous god visiting
the iniquity of the fathers upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of them
that hate me and showing mercy unto thousands
of them that love me and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord thy god
in vain for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the sabbath of the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter
thy manservant nor thy maidservant nor thy
cattle nor thy stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day wherefore the lord
blessed the sabbath day and hallowed it honor thy
father and thy mother that thy days may be long
upon the land which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness against thy
neighbor thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
wife nor his manservant nor his maidservant
nor his orcs nor his ass nor anything that is
thy neighbors god is good that's weak god is good
and all the time happy sabbath
everyone if you love god say amen
god heard it and god is pleased i am grateful
to god for this high honor of speaking for him
i will do the best i can within my limited
capacity to deliver thus saith the lord
that alone will change your lives my opinions
have absolutely no value so i will keep them
jealously to myself is there anyone among us who
is not a seventh-day adventist merit your hand
anyone among us you are not a seventh of the
adventist mercy your hand may i see anyone who
has made a decision to be baptized may i see your
hand ah i like you and you and you i like you too
and you and you i'm liking a lot of people it is
the most intelligent decision you can make which
goes along with a decision to give your life to
jesus christ and there are two good reasons to
give your life to christ one you live with him
when he comes you escape the horrors of hell
two your life really belongs to him to refuse
to give the life to christ is to practice
theft the earth is the lord's and the fullness
thereof the world and they that dwell therein
i am not speaking from the book of revelation i
am speaking literally your life belongs to god
to withhold it from god is to steal and the
bible says as you just heard thou shalt not
steal and so even before i get into the message
stop stealing from god and give him your life
all honest people say amen there are few of you
who are not but i understand i welcome our family
at born again and our family at missouri city
wherever you are god bless you it is tremendous
honor to be a member of the family of god the
church on earth and the church in heaven are one
is this mike working the church on earth
and the church in heaven come on are one
you know jesus said to mary go and tell peter
i ascend to my father and to your father
to my god and to your god the god of jesus the
father jesus is our father and so jesus told
us to pray our father which art in heaven come
on said hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done how as it is in heaven
because heaven and earth must be won
our subject for today dressed for
the occasion what did i say dress
for the occasion before i get into that let me ask
you first to preserve reverence wherever you are
god loves reverence and he rewards those who
practice reverence and i'm not referring to that
accident so please think i am i am not accidents
happen in an imperfect world but go on sin no
more favor number two i want you to pray for me
while i'm speaking all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth that is
based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 which says
then the lord put forth his hand and touched
my mouth thus the divine and the human and the
lord said unto me behold i devi have put my words
divine in thy mouth human and i want god's words
placed in my mouth and favor number three i want
you to think as you listen don't just sit with
an open brain and allow me to pour things into
your head think filter and your filter is thus
saith the lord isaiah 1 18 come now let us
reason together saith the lord let's pray
how father in heaven we come into your presence
for the single purpose of worshiping you the
god of heaven and earth we thank you for your
love day god your love for us is so stubborn
we thank you for it forgive us
where we have offended you father
we did not mean to christ died that we might be
forgiven grant us that forgiveness now we pray
replace our sin with righteousness father
as we embark on this portion of the service
grant us your spirit day god to continue
supervising what we do speak through me
they god that the words i speak may be words
from the throne of glory the throne of grace
the throne of truth father bless all those
listening in person via in electronic connection
if they're visitors connecting their god wherever
they are i appeal to you in the name of jesus
grant them a special blessing there may be little
boys and little girls listening father jesus
was at one point a little boy bless them because
they too can understand much more than we suspect
i humble myself before you they god i am a carnal
person i'm flesh i am dirt i am clay i'm of the
earth but i love to speak for you suppress my
carnal nature take it by the throat and choke it
into submission day god that your glory becomes my
only business bless every country represented by
the listening audience teach the leaders their god
that righteousness exalteth the nation and also
exalts the individual who practices righteousness
heal anyone listening who has the covet 19 father
deliver that person or those persons from that
horrible affliction restore them to health and
let them chew let them receive that expression
of goodness as father a reason for them to come
closer to you bless this country of the united
states guide the decisions of the leaders
that their decisions may allow the gospel to go
forward keep us faithful day god save us when you
come without losing one i pray in jesus name let
god's people say amen and amen what's our subject
dress for the occasion a little slow dressed for
the occasion your adventist you ought to be fast
dressed video go with me to
second peter chapter three
quickly we used to be called the people of
the book notice i said we used to be called
the people of the book we need to get that title
back second be to three let's read from verse nine
verse 9 of 2nd peter 3. lord verse
9 sorry verse 10. do you have that
but the day of the lord i read from the king james
version you may feel free to read with me but the
day of the lord will come as a thief in the night
in the which the heavens shall pass away with
a great noise and the elements shall melt with
fervent heat the earth also and the works that are
therein shall be burned up seeing then that all
these things shall be what dissolve what manner
of persons ought to be in all holy conversation
and godliness looking for and hasting unto the
coming of the day of god wherein the heavens being
on fire shall be dissolved and the elements shall
melt with fervent heat now let me hear a chorus
of voices reading verse 13 come on nevertheless
come on we according to his promise look for what
new heavens come on and new earth finish the first
wearing dwelleth righteousness
there are some churches where
all members dress the same way
i frequently go to south africa there
are some churches they meet under trees
and all the people wear white of course
you can't try that in this church
but all the people who are white so
no one has to compare with the other
there are no fashion problems they all wear
men and women in white in the army there are no
fashion problems they all dress the same way but
um i said that to say this dress can identify you
did i speak error or did i speak truth dress can
identify you now the bible says we are headed
for the world and the heavens wherein dwelleth
righteousness the lifestyle is all righteousness
go to revelation 19. 10 minutes to 12 i have to
speak at one o'clock for a church in new york
but i won't rush if you find the passages quickly
what book did i say revelation what chapter
19 let's read from verse 7. are you
there read with me what does this say
let us rejoice come on and be glad and give
honor to why for the marriage of the lamb is come
and his wife have made herself ready verse
eight and two her was what granted that she
should be what arrayed in fine lining clean
and white finish the verse for the fine linen
is the righteousness of the same in that verse
righteousness is symbolized how as a garment
go to revelation 16.
our subject dress for the occasion let's
read verse 15 nice a lot what does this say
behold i come how as a thief keep reading blessed
is he that what watcheth and keepeth his garment
lest he walk naked and they see his shame here
again we see righteousness symbolized as a garment
let's go to revelation chapter 3.
revelation the book where all
other books find their fulfillment
eloise says when the books of daniel
and revelation are better understood
there will be a change a reformation
a revival among god's people
revelation what chapter did i say what verse 18
are you there read with me what does that say
i counsel thee buy of me gold tried in the
fire that thou mayest be rich keep reading
carefully now and a white raymond come on that
thou mayest be clothed and that the shame of thy
nakedness do not appear here again we have
righteousness symbolized as a garment now
we are headed for a new world where the lifestyle
is what righteousness then how should we dress
righteousness should be our garment let's
add to that let us go to acts 17 acts
17. the book of acts written by whom uh
that's a good guess but i have to flunk you
luke luke yeah luke two books what are the two
books lou connect that's okay what book did i say
acts what chapter 17 what verse 31 read for me
what's that saying because he hath appointed a day
in the which you will judge the world
how in righteousness come on by that man
whom he hath okay now that's fine he will
judge the world someday in righteousness
it makes sense that the world is judged in
righteousness if we are preparing to enter
what new world wherein dwelleth righteousness
god is consistent let us go to second timothy
chapter four our subject dress for the occasion
second timothy chapter four who wrote that book
paul yes god bless you second timothy four
will read seven and eight and god bless
you for bringing your bibles and for loving the
truth i really mean that sincerely read with me
i have fought a good fight i have finished
my course i have kept the faith stop
don't answer me i'm about to ask you a
question are you fighting a good fight
there are some people who expect god to
just change them with no effort from them
i have fought a good fight first timothy
chapter 6 verse 12 paul tells timothy
fight the good fight of faith the half-brother of
jesus christ james in james chapter 4 verse 7 he
says submit yourself therefore to god resist this
is not lie down and god saved me there must be an
effort jesus says come unto me the bible says if
he confess let's go back to second timothy chapter
four seven and eight i have fought a good fight
i have finished my course i have kept the faith
read verse 8 clearly henceforth there's notice
notice henceforth henceforth because of this
my faithfulness to god by the power of
christ there's laid up for me there's
a connection between that crown of
righteousness and the life you live
now you cannot save yourself you cannot mass
produce righteousness but there is a connection
between the life we live and whether or not
we are admitted to that righteous new world
henceforth verse 8 read with me there is
leader for me what a crown of righteous stuff
describe the world that god has provided for us
it's a righteous world tell me about the
judgment that will decide who enters that world
it's in righteousness tell me about the crown
that we shall receive it's a righteous crime
now let's read it again henceforth
laid up for me a crown of righteousness
which the lord the righteous judge how do you
describe the judge of that judgment he's righteous
then what do we need above anything
else come on what the righteousness
what's the central teaching of the bible
righteousness by faith what
god does for us and in us
through jesus christ righteousness by faith and
so we're looking for let me pray again father
continue to be with me help me to be patient with
your people bless us lord i pray be glorified and
bless us in jesus name i pray amen a righteous
new world a righteous judgment a righteous judge
a righteous crown the central teaching
of the bible righteousness but what is
righteousness go to jeremiah 23.
jeremiah 23 we'll read verses 5 and 6.
we're trying to answer the
question what is righteousness
you have jeremiah 23
5 and 6.
can we read now if you have my version
you may read me what does that say
behold the days come said the lord that i
will raise unto whom david a righteous branch
and the king shall reign and prosper and he shall
execute judgment and justice in the earth verse 6
keep reading in his days judah shall be saved
and israel shall dwell safely finish the verse
and this is his name whereby he shall be
called come on the lord our righteousness
question for you what is righteousness jesus
so i should have said who is righteousness
the foundational definition
of righteousness is jesus
but when jesus made us by the way it was
jesus who made us well who made adam and eve
can someone give jesus credit and say amen
what am i doing wrong nobody says anything
it was christ who said let there be light it
was jesus who said let there be a firmament
and the father himself in hebrews 10 tells
the sun but thou lord in the beginning has
laid the foundation of the earth and the
heavens at the works of thy hands do you
understand that the man who said on the cross it
is finished is the one who said let there be light
he is righteousness when he said in genesis 1 26
let us make man in our image after our likeness
we were to be like him then we are to be
like him now if his righteousness we are
to reflect that righteousness jesus christ is
righteousness go to first corinthians chapter one
our subject dress for the occasion first
corinthians chapter 1 we'll read verse 30.
first corinthians written by whom paul yes paul
wrote about one quarter of the new testament
luke's two books make up one another quarter of
the new testament first corinthians 1 reading
verse 30. when you found that say amen what does
that say read for me what does this say but of him
are ye in christ jesus who of god
is made unto us come on wisdom and
righteousness and sanctification and
redemption that verse says jesus is our wisdom
jesus is our redemption of righteousness jesus
is our sanctification and our righteousness
listen to jesus i am the way i am the truth i
am the life which is slightly different from
i have a way and i have a truth and i have
life no i am truth i am the way i am life
john 15 1 i am the true vine that's why he was
the great i am or is when he told moses go and
say to the israelites i am have said me unto you
i am the good shepherd i am the door of the sheep
i am the resurrection and the life jesus is wisdom
jesus is righteousness jesus is sanctification
jesus is redemption meaning there is
no righteousness outside of christ
there is no wisdom that heaven uh approves
outside of jesus christ there is no redemption
outside of christ there is no righteousness
outside of christ he is our righteousness
so when you have christ dwelling in you
righteousness dwells in you so christ but
let's look at righteousness again what is
righteousness let us go to deuteronomy chapter
six let's read verse 25 our subject dressed
for the occasion deuteronomy 6
reading verse 25 who wrote deuteronomy
moses well he wrote most of it the chapter
about his death he couldn't write deuteronomy 6
let's read verse 25 let me pray regard remind
me that i am here for your glory alone in jesus
name i pray amen deuteronomy 6 25 are you there
read with me what does it say and it shall be
our righteousness if we observe to do what all
these commandments come on before the lord our god
as he hath commanded us then righteousness
is associated with god's commandments
go to matthew 20 not 20 matthew 12.
quickly matthew 12.
let's read verse 34 i want you to read
microscopically concentrate as you read matthew 12
reading verse 34 do you have that read with me
what does it say o generation of vipers how can ye
be evil speak good things finish the verse for out
of the abundance of the heart the mouth speaketh
what comes out of the mouth originates
where in the heart for us and for god
desire of eighties page 19 paragraph two ella
white writes the law which seeketh not her own
has its source in the heart of god the love
i should say which seeketh not his her own
has its source in the heart
of god now when the voice said
thou shalt have no other gods before me
from where did that come the heart of god
what did jesus say in matthew 12 34 out of the
ear the heart speaking the mouth speaketh when
that voice said remember the sabbath day to
keep it holy what was the origin of those words
come on tell me the heart of god then from
where the commandments come the heart of god
now the bible says this is the whole duty of man
please think
the whole duty of man is
to express the heart of god
but since we're limited it is expressed
in ten commandments you following me
now jesus says the commandments are
love to god love your fellow man
the holy spirit told moses to write it
shall be our righteousness if we observe
to do how many of these commandments are
then you may say oh then i can save myself
let me obey listen to jesus we must study here a
little they're little without me finish my words
you can do nothing particularly keep those
commandments yes it shall be of righteousness if
we observe to do but how will we observe to do
through the indwelling of jesus christ because
actually it is he that does it through us with our
permission this was how jesus lived go to john 14.
john 14 my second favorite book john beautiful
book written by the disciple who was closest to
christ and of whom eloise said he most perfectly
reflected the character of christ above all the
other disciples the one who leaned on jesus
breast he was so close that peter said to him
you ask him who shall betray him never let someone
tell never ask someone to tell you what jesus said
ask jesus yourself are you following me you be
so close that you ask him yourself but peter said
ask him peter can you ask himself anyway let's
get back to john 14. let's read from verse 8.
philip said unto him lord show us the father
and it sufficeth us jesus saith unto him have i
been so long time with you and yet hast thou not
known me philip he that have seen me have seen the
father and how says thou then show us the father
believers thou not keep reading with me now that i
am in the father and the father in me keep reading
the words that i speak unto you i speak not of
myself come on but the father that dwelleth in
me finished the verse that's how jesus lived
now here's how we should live galatians
2 20 don't go there just saying
i am crucified with christ nevertheless i live
yet not i but christ liveth in me keep reading
and the life which i now live in the
flesh i live by the faith of the son
of god who loved me and gave himself for me
as verily as jesus was indwelt by the father
and the father works through him we are to be
inbuilt by christ that christ may work through us
and when that's the case the lives we live
are righteous lies and so deuteronomy 6 25
and it shall be our righteousness if we observe
to do the word if introduces what a condition
as much as god loves us he will not
save us contrary to our will when he
made adam he did not ask adam would
you like to be made he just made him
we know what adam did now god is
asking us do you want me to remake you
he gets our permission first before he
puts us in that new world he just made adam
then said do you want to stay adam said
no by virtue of his sin now as i said god
is making us for god is first seeking our
permission getting us right then he'll place
us in that new world by our request the
father lived in jesus in a mysterious way
and christ must live in us the same mysterious
way that we might live righteous lives our subject
dressed for the occasion we're heading for a world
where everyone wears what a righteous character
go to psalm 119. psalm 119 looks like 10 after
12 or some such thing psalm 119 and my family had
born again and the bay town the port i'm still
with you god bless you and whoever is listening
wherever you are in new york kuala lumpur god
bless you god bless you we're all one through the
spirit psalm 119 verse 172 i want you to read that
clearly and loudly read with me what does it say
my tongue psalm 119 verse 172 what does that say
my tongue shall speak of thy finish the verse
for all thy commandments are righteousness
in other words it is righteous not to steal
that's one amen anymore it is
righteous to keep the sabbath
then what is it to not keep the sabbath
give me a smaller word a smaller word sin
because the opposite of righteousness is sin
if righteousness is the law
sin is the violation of the law
all thy commandments are righteousness the only
way to live a righteous life in the eyes of god
now you may live a righteous life in the eyes
of the government and they'll give you a medal
and you wear that medal to hell to live
a righteous life in the eyes of god
that life may be consistent must be
consistent with god's commandments
but only by the power of christ whose very
life is an expression of the commandments
stay in psalm 119 let's go to psalm 1 verse
142. psalm 119 verse 142. are you there
what does that say thy righteousness come on is
an everlasting righteousness come on and thy law
is the truth what's the law give me another word
for the law the ten commandments we're not saved
by keeping the ceremonial law we're saved by
jesus but christ calls us to live by the ten
commandments the bible doesn't say the ceremonial
law is the whole duty of man the kingdom of the
commandments is the whole duty of man so when
you read thy righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness thy law is the truth righteousness
and the law are virtually the same thing
because the law thy commandments are righteousness
go to verse 144 verse 144 of psalm 119 do you have
that read with me come on the righteousness
of thy testimonies is stop read verse 142
thy righteousness is an everlasting righteousness
144 says the righteousness of thy testimony
is everlasting it's precisely the same thing
because the testimonies refer to the commandments
go to exodus 31 you look at me strangely
exodus 31. god is good and all the time
may i say that you look like very nice people
you really do did i speak the truth say amen
okay what book did i say exodus what chapter
31 reading verse 18. when you found it
say amen if you're still looking say amen
all right read with me and he gave unto moses
when he had made an end of communion with him
upon mount sinai come on two tables of testimony
incubating tables of stone written with the finger
of god now what are the two tables of testimony
the ten commandments why
testimony what is the testimony
it's what a witness gives are you with me
you give your testimony you say what you know
the law expressed the character of god they are
witness to the character of god otherwise says god
is as sacred as his law or the law is the sacred
god himself they are a testimony of the unselfish
character of god that's what i call test
the arc is called the ark of the testimony
because the purpose of the ark was to carry
the ten commandments the purpose of the entire
tabernacle was the ten commandments let me
pray father as i enter this phase give me
the right word dear god please in jesus name
amen listen to me carefully reason with me
this side when you entered when you when a sinner
brought his animal to the priest what's the first
section of the tabernacle he entered the
outer court was that holy yes or no yes
when the killing was done the blood was collected
sometimes the priest took the blood and went where
to the holy place was that holy
was it holier than the outer court
is the outer court called holy
is the outer court called holy no but was it holy
yes now was the holy place holy between the holy
place and the outer court which was holier the
holy place now where did the priest go once a year
the most early was it holier than the
holy was it holier than the outer court
so we have degrees of holiness yes or no come
on sit with confidence yes or no yes we have
degrees of holiness the sinner could come to the
outer court he could not enter the holy place
the levites could enter the holy place
they could not enter the most holy we
have degrees of holiness now you tell
me where was the altar of sacrifice
come on where's the art of sacrifice in the outer
court where was the liver in the outer court
is this an adventist church it is hi father where
was the candlestick quickly where was the bread
the interventions yes now all these
things are highly significant am i right
the altar represented what calvary delivered
the washing of the word and the spirit
the candlestick the light the bread the word
all the vincents the intercession of christ
those are absolutely essential but
they were not in the most holy place
what really is the main
article in the most holy place
they are but what is the function of the ark to
house the ten comma now you tell me reason with me
could god have put the ten
commandments in the outer court
he can do anything he wants let me
ask you again and so redeem yourselves
could god have put the law in the
outer court yes because he's god
you don't want to see me angry come on you
adventist could god have put the law in the
holy place where did he put it in the mouth
holy now you tell me what does that mean
god the character of god
the essence of god righteousness as expressed in
the law or the law of love in the most holy place
when the priest entered the most holy
place all sins had to be forgiven
if he entered the most holy with one sin in
his life you tell me the unpleasant details
drop dead the garments of the priest on the
hem they were bells now jewish tradition
tells us a rope was tied around his waist
and it extended right out of the tabernacle
now as he moved ministering what did they hear
the bells when the bells stopped ringing you
know what happened he was dead but you couldn't
go get him unless you wanted to join him in death
what did they do they used a rope to pull him out
the most holy place and the thing in
that place was the law eloy says the
ark was merely a receptacle for the the
precepts it was the presence of these
precepts that gave to the ark its sacredness
and importance otherwise it was just wood
it was the presence of the ten commandments
that made the ark untouchable you ask aza if you
don't believe me you know who aza was all right
that law expressed righteousness now the bible
says nevertheless we according to his promise
and what god promises he keeps if we fulfill
the conditions look for new heavens new earth
wherein dwelleth righteousness go to isaiah 48
isaiah 48
let's read verse 18.
isaiah 48 very beautiful book by the way isaiah
more than any other old testament book talks about
jesus that's why he's called the gospel prophet
you have isaiah 48 verse 18 let me pray father
in heaven continue to be with me the god please i
pray for my heart in jesus name amen read with me
oh that thou had hearken to my what stop
how do you what do you think the prophet
is feeling when he said all that thou has
heartened unto what do you think he's feeling
what's this sound like is he
speaking calmly is is it a crisis
is he broken up is he distressed all that thou
has hearkened to my commandments keep reading
then have thy peace be what as a river
keep reading and thy righteousness
as the waves of the sea now the prophet is
attaching peace and righteousness to what
heartening to the commandments of god
if you want peace of mind obey god
ministry of healing page 480 paragraph three four
eight zero paragraph three many who profess to be
christ followers have an anxious trouble heart
because they are afraid to trust themselves with
god they do not make a complete surrender to
him for they shrink from the consequences that
such a surrender may involve unless they
make this surrender they cannot have peace
and so isaiah says o that thou has heartened to my
commandments then hath thy peace being as a river
and thy righteousness as the waves of
the sea as a matter of fact the bible
says the consciousness of right doing not the
bible white is the best medicine for disease
bodies and minds he that is at peace with god
has secured the most important requisite to
health health for living page 233 paragraph seven
listen again the consciousness of right doing
i know i'm trying to obey god try not to offend
him by his grace the consciousness of right doing
is the best medicine for diseased bodies
and minds he that is at peace with god
because he tries to obey god has secured
the most important requisite to health
and i listen to many advertised presentations
in health and to give the eight health laws and
call them new start and whatever else
but no one ever says confess your sins
the number one health law is confess your
sins because sin is the source of sickness
i don't mean to digress but sin is the
source of sickness whether sins you commit
or simply living in a sinful world remove sin
sickness goes death goes wars go prisons jails
divorce everything and god desires
for us not sin but righteousness
now it's uh 20 after 12. can i have 15
more minutes say yes all right let's pray
father in heaven continue to be with me i pray i
beg you in the name of jesus amen go to romans 5.
romans 5 and after that we'll jump over
to genesis 2 and 3. and i preach on those
passages more than any other i suspect
because some people just don't get it
romans 5 we're looking at verse 19.
do you have that i want just the men to read if
the men have my version men do you have my version
king j all right read with me men you're the
leaders strong voices for as by one man's
disobedience come on many were made sinners keep
reading so by the obedience of one shall many be
made righteous stop how many men are in that verse
how many times you see the word man or one twice
who are the men adam come on and jesus the second
adam the bible says as by one man's disobedience
based on all we've said give me an
intelligent definition of disobedience
that's true but i want another word put in there
what is disobedience yes you're right but the base
of all i've said unrighteousness i like that man
handsome man reminds me of myself unrighteousness
unrighteousness um for us by one man's
unrighteousness and we can see that by
reading verse 18 now ladies you read verse 18. are
you there read for me ladies what does that say
therefore as by what no start
again therefore as by the offense
come on of one judgment came upon
all men too condemnation go on
ah by the right so we have in verse 18 offense
and righteousness as opposites we have in 19
obedience and disobedience those two verses are
saying what the same thing but look at the words
in verse 18 we have offense do you see it
what's the equivalent to offense in verse 19
ah sister god bless you disobedience do we have
in verse 18 righteousness come on do you see that
what's the equivalent in 19 obedience
and what is righteousness obedience
what is sin disobedience
what world are we preparing for a world of
our world of a world of obedience to god
where obedience is your genetic desire
even as disobedience is our genetic desire
now before we convert it that's why we have to be
born again so we come into the world now with new
spiritual genetic information which says i delight
to do thy will o my god yeah thy law is within my
heart this is the result of conversion the new
birth and it can only be done by a divine power
jesus tells us in john 3 verse 8 the wind bloweth
where it listeth and now here's the sound thereof
but can't not tell whence it cometh or whether
it goeth so is everyone that is born of the
spirit only a divine being can make that change
sociology cannot psychology therapy they have
their place don't misunderstand me eu therapists
the new birth can only be accomplished by a divine
power because it requires the rewriting of genetic
information at the spiritual level so as fairly
as a sinners urges to sin a converted person's
urge is to do right you look at me puzzled
that which is born of the flesh is
flesh that which is born of the spirit
is mirror listen to ellen white mind captain
personality volume 2 page 601 paragraph 4
that which at first seems difficult by constant
repetition grows easy and right thoughts and
actions become habitual i am saying to you as
truly as a carnal person naturally prefers sin
the converted person learns to prefer
righteousness and will die rather than sin
what's our subject
dressed for the occasion what
is the dress we should all wear
righteousness go to not nehemiah zechariah chapter
three i'm coming to the end is 25 well i'll take
five more minutes you gave me 15. we have a few
left zechariah chapter three we read from verse
one our subject dress for the occasion and by
the way baptism is an act of righteousness i
hope the spirit reminds me to get into that
briefly baptism is an act of righteousness
when the minister baptizes you that is an act
of righteousness zechariah 3 reading from verse
1 father in heaven continue to be with me please
god in jesus name i pray amen read with me and he
showed me joshua the high priest standing before
the angel of the lord and satan standing where at
his right hand to resist him by the way every day
that's the devil's work resist resist oppose make
your life miserable christ is there to give us
power and power and power right hand to resist him
and verse two what does that say and the
lord said the lord rebuked thee o satan
even the law that have chosen jerusalem rebuke
thee is not this a brand plucked out of the fire
whether the fire is drugs alcohol financial
mismanagement god can pluck you out of that fire
verse three now read carefully now joshua
was clothed filthy garments representing
what quickly sin and stood before the angel
and he answered and speaking of those that
stood before him saying what take away the filthy
garments from him and unto him he said what behold
i have caused thine iniquity to pass from thee
and i will clothe thee with change of raiment
i will do that that's god i will remove and i
will pay it put on you the same way god removed
the aprons and put on the coats of skins and that
new garment is righteousness that old garment sin
but god puts it not on our skins he puts it in
our hearts you see because out of the abundance
of the heart the mouth speaketh the hands act the
feet act everything proceeds elohwhite writes in
christ object lessons page 316 every act is judged
by the motive and motives come from here not here
i will clothe thee with change of raymond when
jesus came to john the baptist to be baptized
john matthew chapter 3 john said
i have need to be baptized of thee
and cometh thou unto me jesus answering said unto
him suffer it to be so now for thus it becometh
us to fulfill finish the words all righteousness
repentance is an act of righteousness
confession is an act of righteousness
baptism is an act of righteousness
if we're preparing for a righteous world we
must practice righteousness in this world
and righteousness in his condensed form is
the ten commandments and so the wisest man
who ever lived who was a ancestor of jesus
christ he said let us hear the conclusion
of the whole matter he writes when he was
an old man now he looks back over his life
because all age has the virtue or the benefit
of a rear view mirror you see you look back
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter no
matter what fear god respect him give him reverend
and keep him if you don't fear god you will
not keep his commandments are you following me
so the kingdom of commandments express your
reference forgotten your love fear god and
keep his commandments for this come on tell me is
the whole duty of man and what's the commandments
all thy commandments are righteousness deuteronomy
6 25 it shall be of righteousness if we observe to
do all these commandments before the lord
our god as he hath commanded us the duty
of the child of god is to live a righteous
life but it can only be lived by the indwelling
power of christ because the righteousness is
ultimately jesus christ himself dwelling in us
and he speaks through us he guides our thoughts
as we stay submitted like clay in the hands of
the potter someone listening to me needs to
practice righteousness by making a decision
to be baptized or to be re-baptized because by
your own assessment your life has not been what it
should be and perhaps the spirit of god has been
convicting you you need to start with god all over
again evangelism page 375 re-baptism reconversion
must take place among the brethren and she says
if a person is truly reconverted let that person
be re-baptized let him renew his covenant with god
and god will renew his covenant with him some
of us listening wherever you are need to make
that decision which is a righteous one to be
baptized into jesus christ because we're told in
galatians 3 27 those who were baptized have put
on christ and we're talking about righteousness
i want you to make a decision to seek the
power of christ to live a righteous life
as you and i anticipate a righteous new world
but prior to the new world we have a righteous
judgment it's based on the ten commandments
the judge presiding is a righteous judge he
appears in our heads come on a righteous crown
and we enter a world where everything is right
angels obey human beings obey those an unfollowed
worlds obey the entire universe will throb
with one harmony of obedience to the creator
righteousness how many of you will say with
me lord i pray as david prayed creating me
a clean heart of god can i see your right hand
stand with me a clean heart is a righteous
one because righteousness has no sin we become
saints overnight no i'm not saying that we grow
in grace but your decision is a hundred percent
you tell me when the mob puts a contract
on you the mafia it may take 10 years to
find you but they'll find you because it is in
the heart to carry out that contract that hit
if your decision is to live a righteous life
by the power of christ that decision is what
god looks at faith and works page 50 i believe it
is 54. ellen white writes when it is in the heart
to obey god when efforts are put forth toward
this end god accepts this disposition and effort
as man's best service and he makes up for the
deficiency with his own divine matter he said
she tried i'll make up for where she fell short
he tried i will make up because god is more
desperate to get you into heaven than we are to
enter but we must make that decision when god told
abraham sacrificed isaac it was in his heart to do
it and the bible writes as if it was actually done
hebrews 11 verse 17 by faith abraham when he was
tried offered up isaac god accepted it as done
because it was done here even though god stabbed
him physically but he accepted it as done if you
make a decision with all your heart and soul
to keep the sabbath holy god accepts that
heads bowed eyes closed dear
god we thank you for your word
we thank you for jesus father he is our
wisdom our righteousness our sanctification
our redemption we thank you for your commandments
that express the righteousness of christ
which is your righteousness we thank you thank
god you've made a way for us to live righteous
lives by the indwelling of our savior as verily
as the human jesus lived the righteous life
by your indwelling of him there are some
people listening to me to god they love you
they need to make the courageous and bold step
to choose to be baptized to make that decision
because that is a righteous decision while your
heads about and your eyes are closed wherever you
are whether here or in born again or missouri city
or wherever you are around the world if the spirit
of god has convicted you make a decision where you
are to be baptized but for those in my presence
if there's someone who has not
yet made a decision to be baptized
ought to start with god all over again and
there are variety of reasons for the why
people may do that either they did it when they
understood nothing they did it and they drifted
from you father or they did it under pressure but
it is someone who needs to make a decision for god
to be baptized or rebaptized and you've not yet
made it and you'll make it now i want you to raise
your right hand you have not yet made it you'll
make it now raise your right hand god bless you
god bless you my brother you've not yet made
it to be re-baptized or baptized raise that
hand who takes names i see those two hands
right here i need someone to write these
we see a third hand off to the left someone come
quickly this is very serious we must get the names
there's a daughter of god right here a daughter
of god back there a son of god to my right so we
have two people pastor sang the brother right here
get his name please read is for baptism rebaptism
get the name we have the sister right here and
we have the sister back there yes sister back
there i believe in the red top we need her name
anyone else if you're at uh missouri city raise
your hand someone will take your name if you're
at dayton report someone will take your name
and wherever you are around the globe if you've
been convicted make a decision and find a seventh
adventist church where you are and let the leaders
know you have made the right decision to be
baptized and all of heaven will be pleased anyone
else a decision for baptism or re-baptism in acts
chapter 19 the first seven verses is the story
of paul re-baptizing 12 disciples anyone else
make one more appeal and it's for everyone
listening to me wherever you are you've been
visiting adventist churches you've loved what
you've heard and the spirit has been moving you in
the direction of accepting this truth and you want
to say father i need to learn just a little more
before i decide if there's someone who will say
i need some extra bible studies before i make the
decision for baptism wherever you are let that be
known to the leaders of the churches where you are
and they will arrange for you to get those studies
because baptism must be an intelligent choice but
do not wait until you know everything that's a
trick of the devil if you know you want to obey
god you know god wants to save you you have enough
and you know god has a standard his law you know
enough to make a decision to be baptized and now
how many will say father thank you for your love
i recommit my life to you can i see your hand i
recommit my life keep your hands up if it does not
hurt father we thank you for your word we thank
you for your love which is so persistent dear god
your love expressed in the death of your son
i pray for my heart father if i said anything
wrong forgive me if i misrepresented you forgive
me father bless every man woman who raised the
hand they are recommitting their lives to you
where their lives rightfully belong please god
bless them individually bless them in the
spirit of steps to christ page 100 paragraph one
the relations between god and each soul are as
direct and full as though there were not another
soul upon the earth to share his watch care not
another soul for whom he gave his beloved son
give them that individual attention
father bless us keep us faithful give us a
love for righteousness dear god and a hatred for
sin because you described jesus in hebrews 1 9
thou has love righteousness and hated
iniquity give us that mind i pray bless
us for the remainder of this day in jesus
name let god's people say amen and amen